I think there's a lot of people who are
very nervous right now because they say
whenever you have a health crisis and an
economic crisis like this the will of
free people gets tested meaning that
they're much more open to receiving
quote-unquote help or having government
implement temporary measures or more
surveillance or things that maybe
wouldn't be as easy to get across the
finish line during a time when there
wasn't those health and economic crises
and so maybe let's just start with like
what how bad the problem really is right
I know that you guys have done some work
on understanding we see data being
presented from countries all around the
world around the health crisis and
economic crisis but just if it is an
authoritarian country like how much can
we believe the data that we're getting
and how do you guys think about kind of
level setting those data sets versus
countries where maybe there's more
democracy or transparency in
confirmation of the numbers and data I'm
really glad you asked us and I want to
unpack it with you and with everybody
who's listening because I think there's
a lot of lessons to draw here first of
all I think we're being led to believe
in many cases especially even in open
societies Western countries that there's
a lot of lessons in authoritarianism and
that we should grant emergency powers to
our rulers in times of crisis and that
like a very strong centralized kind of
response is probably best and that maybe
we even want to grant extraordinary
surveillance powers and that there's a
lot to learn from China and the Chinese
government and I think this is the very
long and dangerous perspective to take I
think that there's this sort of cultural
war that's starting to happen to bubble
over where it's arguably not even so
much a war as a battle that's almost
being almost won by a particular side
and that's again the side of you know
the public
safety is more important than civil
liberties and again these are arguments
coming from mainstream people the
mainstream media and a lot of
technologists actually who are like well
whatever privacy who cares what's more
important now is that we save lives and
then and they kind of look to China and
China's quote unquote performance as
validation of their argument and what
you're starting to see is people become
very less a fair about about their
rights and freedoms because they they're
just focused on what the what they're
learning about kovat and and how
potentially these governments can
protect them what's very very important
to understand is that the performance of
authoritarian governments is not what it
seems so you might look at the data now
that the Financial Times or New York
Times is reporting you constantly see
these little charts that the Financial
Times puts out of cases and deaths in it
it shows all these countries kind of
like going up over time and then it
shows China with this like amazing
flattening of the curve and now it looks
like things are cool they're now and the
Financial Times as one of the papers of
record of them in the world to be honest
kind of repeats this day daily over and
over and over again they're hitting
people over the head with the idea that
China has solved the problem and the
problem the core problem is the core
issue is the Financial Times is
regurgitating data from the Chinese
Communist Party they're regurgitating
lies the Chinese Communist Party
remember has been lying for the last
half decade to the world about the
prison camps in gulags and Xinjiang in
the northwest part of China in the
northwest part of China we can see from
outer space using satellite imagery that
there are vast numbers a huge network of
concentration camps prison camps where
the CCP the Chinese Communist Party is
imprisoning male Weaver's they are a
Muslim minority ethnic minority and they
are imprisoning according to the latest
estimates we have anywhere from 1 to 2
million people in these camps and this
is such a shocking thing such a visible
thing see it from outer space and yet
they lie and deny that they exist
so we're gonna take this regime's word
that there's whatever it is 4,000 deaths
is what they're reporting and all the
mainstream media and all of our
policymakers and all of these
influencers in Silicon Valley are
basically looking at China and saying
yeah we might have to you know follow
some of their measures they've you know
I know you know they're like well you
know they might be doing some things we
don't like but you know you can't deny
the the results and I'm telling you you
need to deny the results those results
are fake
there are extensive reports in who've a
province where Wuhan is where the
epicenter of the outbreak originally
started where people have just been
watching the funeral homes and they've
just been looking at the urns that are
coming in and out and this was back like
a month ago but basically local
residents estimated that there had to be
at least 40,000 deaths based on just
what they saw in that one city alone
okay I would be shocked if the actual
number of Cova deaths in China was less
than 1/4 million I'd shocked and yet the
news media you know and I say that in a
in a kind of half loving way I mean Free
Press is really important but people
have become so gullible
in believing what China is saying that
we're kind of getting sucked into this
mindset that we should be more like them
like there are so many arguments and
articles written by influencers in
Britain in the United States saying
there's a lot to learn from China and
I'm telling you yes there is a lot to
learn from China we should run as far
away from their government model as
possible and the final piece to this
puzzle is that if it is true that we
should seek a more authoritarian
structure in our societies so that we
can handle public health crises more
effectively let's just give them the
benefit of doubt and say that that's
that's their honest argument then we
need to consider the fact that how is it
possible that the one of the most
authoritarian governments from the world
one of the most secretive governments in
the world the government that has the
most censorship and surveillance per
capita of any Society in human history
did such a bad job controlling the
outbreak at the beginning
in December and in January that you know
even with all their Orwellian
surveillance Tech and all the control
they had and all of this strong
centralization under Xi Jinping they
failed the virus became an outbreak and
has killed untold numbers of Chinese and
devastated their economy and you know
has basically ruined the their their
global brand so if they couldn't stop
this thing with all the centralized
control and surveillance in the world
then I think the lessons that we need to
draw are that we need to take a
different approach we need to fight this
particular crisis kovat other public
health crises and any sort of national
disaster whether it be from another
nation state or from a natural
perspective economic perspective we need
to fight these things with a spirit of
openness and innovation and a free flow
of information if we allow the kind of
axes of censorship and control and
surveillance to win the day we're not
gonna like the results